oh hi on this week's game life i would
like to share with you my thoughts on a
new downloadable game for playstation 3
called papo eo now what makes this game
stand out from the pack is that it's
actually an autobiographical story and
not a very happy one its creator vander
caballero created this as sort of an
allegorical story of his childhood in
which he had to grow up with an abusive
alcoholic father
in papua yo the young boy main character
kiko is friends slash enemies with this
giant monster and he can be helpful
except when he eats the poisonous frogs
that he's addicted to which caused him
to go into a violent rage
the game itself is an environmental
puzzle caballero says that he was mostly
inspired by sony's game eco the thing is
popo eo is really really easy the
puzzles can be slightly puzzling but it
really doesn't take that long before you
find the solution every time
i played popo eo after a lot of other
critics had already weighed in and i saw
that they all kind of made the same
point there's not a lot of gameplay here
i think this was deliberate in general
people don't finish video games bioware
the makers of rpgs like mass effect has
tracked this and they've said that for
example only 36 percent of people
finished dragon age origins
now popo eo is a 4-hour download not a
40-hour role-playing game so it's
probably much more completable for the
average gamer but because its strength
is in the storyline and because to truly
understand what caballero was getting at
you've got to see everything i think the
design team were really pushing to make
papo eo frictionless they wanted to make
sure nobody ever got stuck
this is kind of a shame since getting
stuck on something and then powering
through it is what makes a video game
feel good
so ultimately anyone else who wants to
try this sort of unique thing pushing
the boundaries of what video games can
be is going to run up against this
problem even if your story is the most
important thing people expect fun
gameplay first and foremost
now i wish that there was an easy answer
to this problem but unfortunately it's
just something that game designers are
going to have to keep dealing with if
they want their games to tackle more
mature subjects in the meantime bearing
in mind its strengths and weaknesses i
would encourage you definitely play popo
eo